[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo émission spéciale la crise
des migrants l'europe en pleine
confusion
l'italie qui ferme ses ports à la cua
russe et ses 630 réfugiés l'espagne qui
les accueillent
l'allemagne via son ministre de
l'intérieur qui veut un durcissement de
la politique migratoire du pays et la
france dans tout cela
la france prend tel vraiment sa part
dans l'accueil des migrants
la france at-elle manqué à son devoir
d'humanité doit-on accueillir davantage
de migrants des questions qui divisent
avant le conseil européen fin juin les
membres de l'union européenne peine à
trouver une position commune au vent
débattre avec nos invités nathalie
griesbeck bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne du groupe des libéraux et
démocrates pour l'europe
or au député de l'est et modem a lié les
manuels macron membre de la commission
des libertés civiles de la justice et
des affaires intérieures vous est aussi
président de la commission spéciale du
parlement européen sur le terrorisme
merci d'être venus face à vos marie
christine vergiat bonjour monsieur vous
êtes députée européenne du front de
gauche
eurodéputé du sud est également membre
de la commission des libertés civiles
on vous a entendu un dénoncé l'attitude
du gouvernement français vis-à-vis de
l'aquarius on va en parler
enfin jean quatremer bonjour merci
d'être venu vous êtes le correspondant
de libération à bruxelles je rappelle à
nos téléspectateurs votre blog coulisses
de bruxelles 1 pour ne rien rater de
l'actualité européen avant de débattre
les images cette semaine le sommet
franco-allemand le président français et
la chancelière allemande ont annoncé
mardi travailler à un accord entre
plusieurs pays l'espace schengen pour
refouler tout demandeur d'asile vers
l'état où il a été enregistré en premier
et il ya aussi la cua russe qui provoque
une dispute entre paris et rome et c'est
l'espagne finalement qui accueille les
naufragés on regarde on réagit juste
après
[Musique]
l'arrivée de l'aquarius et ses 630
migrants à son bord ils peuvent enfin
souffler en espagne après une semaine de
mer les réfugiés ont débarqué dimanche
dernier sur le port de valence 26
nationalités sont représentées
chaque migrant à son arrivée a été
enregistré ils ont déjà fait savoir dans
quel pays souhaitait se rendre
la france est la destination la plus
demandée mais pour obtenir l'asile en
france
il faut qu'ils soient menacés dans leur
pays d'origine
tous ne l'obtiendront peut-être pas mais
ce bug en allemagne emmanuel macron
rencontre une chancelière allemande
fragilisé politiquement son ministre de
l'intérieur veut un durcissement de la
politique migratoire du pays
il menace d'instaurer un contrôle aux
frontières dès le début de juillet le
président français en est convaincu face
à la crise
la réponse doit être européenne nous
croyons très profondément à une réponse
européenne face aux défis migratoires
ce défi nous ne venons pas de le
découvrir
nous n'avons pas découvert la semaine
dernière mais nous sommes très
clairement ensemble déterminé à agir de
manière européenne et de manière
coordonnée
la france prend elle vraiment sa part en
2015 lors de la crise migratoire et de
l'afflux massif de réfugiés sur les
côtes méditerranéennes
la france s'était engagée comme ses
voisins européens à accueillir une
partie des réfugiés des quotas mis en
place par la commission européenne soit
pour la france
la prise en charge de plus de 19 mille
migrants débarqués sur les côtes
grecques et italiennes
pourtant trois ans plus tard le pays
n'en a recueilli que 5 milles
si l'afflux de migrants s'est réduit en
europe depuis la crise de 2015
les chiffres sur la situation en mer
sont dramatiques
plus de quinze mille migrants trouvé la
mort en trois ans en tentant de
traverser la méditerranée
[Musique]
à la question toute simple est ce que la
france respecte ses engagements
vis-à-vis des demandeurs d'asile marie
christine vergiat pas la réponse est non
ça vient d'être ça vient d'être
démontrée mais peut-être avant faut-il
qu'on appelle de quoi on parle parce que
nous sommes aujourd'hui la journée
mondiale des réfugiés et donc les
réfugiés ce sont des gens qui ont des
droits des protections particulières ce
ne sont pas les migrants général et
peut-être faut-il rappeler que chaque
année l'union européenne accepte sur son
sol deux millions cinq cent mille en
moyenne depuis 2002 sans que ça ait de
changement en moyenne 2 millions 500
mille migrants en situation régulière
donc qu'est ce qui se passe en
méditerranée il se passe qu'il y a des
gens qui n'ont pas de voix régulière
pour venir sur le territoire de l'union
européenne
c'est ce que dit le parlement européen
en permanence nous puis il faut faire du
sauvetage en mer il faut accorder des
cours des couloirs humanitaires il faut
accorder des visas humanitaires
j'ai été shadows avec monsieur lopez
aguilar sur cette question du code des
visas
le conseil les états membres ont refusé
cette porte de visa humanitaire ça c'est
le moyen d'empêcher les morts en
méditerranée
alors après la france dans tout cela et
bien non la france n'a pas pris sa part
dans dans le dans le système elle est
loin d'accueil
et dans les états tiers de façon à ce
que justement des centaines de gens ne
n'embarque pas sur des barques assez
soit la proie des attendez je veux finir
la proie des passeurs et d'aider des
systèmes mafieux de criminalité
organisée
pour arriver sur le territoire européen
et ensuite être éventuellement des
personnes qui ne répondant pas aux
critères de l'asile seraient renvoyés
dans leurs états membres passent peut
par exemple sur les les personnes qui
ont qui était sur la cua russes toute
une partie de ces personnes ne répondent
pas aux critères de l'asile est bon
d'être renvoyée sur par me lasser chez
eux dans la tendance est au mieux éviter
de continuer de faire de la méditerranée
n'ont pas le berceau de la civilisation
européenne mais le cimetière de notre
civilisation comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui quatremer est-ce que ce
refus d'accueillir les migrants à
constate et rêvent les papes plébiscité
au niveau européen dans l'opinion
européenne parce que le problème de
l'immigration le problème des réfugiés
s'est pas seulement un problème européen
c'est d'abord et avant tout un problème
de politique intérieure à dire que
pourquoi emmanuel macron s'est montrée
aussi peu généreux laissant son ministre
de l'intérieur affirmé que les côtes
espagnoles étaient plus proches que les
côtes françaises de l'aquarius allait
quand même être gonflé ici je connais un
peu sa géographie en plus tiré trois
jours avant le bac sortir une énormité
pareille et dix jours où gérard collomb
ferait mieux de la fermer
franchement via l'accord de la corse
était juste à côté même je dirais est
tout simplement marseille est tout
simplement ce que fait manuel macron
c'est la politique intérieure faut voir
que le refus d'accueillir l'aquarius 56
% d'approbation d'après un sondage donc
des sondés 75 % ont condamné la clé les
accusations portées par emmanuel macron
contre l'italie non pas parce pas parce
qu'ils sont solidaires de l'italie qui
accueille et parce que l'italie pour les
français a eu raison de ne pas accepter
l'aquarius qu'est ce que vous voyez
manuel macron qu'est ce que vous voyez
françois hollande avant lui x1000 55%
des français contre l'accueil
oui de la cua russe dans un port
français selon un sondage
qu'est ce qu'on voit dans nos rangs pour
publics semblent tous les pays où on n'a
pas trop se montrer ou généreux
on a laissé passer des migrants et des
réfugiés et bien l'extrême droite est au
pouvoir proche du pouvoir augmente ses
scores il est gêné en france qu'on ait
fait comme angela merkel en 2015 qui moi
personnellement c'est ce que je suis
favorable à ce genre de politique nous
concentrons pas mais c'est une analyse
froide on aurait accueilli en 2015 un
million de réfugiés
on avait marine le pen au pouvoir en
2012 m c'est aussi simple que ça elle a
resserré dont il a été au second tour
mais dont elle serait passée à mon avis
donc il faut bien voir que emmanuel
macron je pense que naturellement il
serait plutôt porté à accueillir
l'aquarius mais là il a voulu envoyer un
signal
les opinions publiques ont l'impression
dé ce serait mme berger pourquoi ils ont
l'impression d'être submergées selon
mace démission par exemple cette
émission depuis une semaine à cause de
l'aquarius c'est moins de 700 personnes
on ne parle que de ça dans les journaux
on ne parle que de ça au niveau
politique je regarde une dépêche de l
afp qui est tombée hier soir et qui
commence par l'arrivée massive et
régulière de migrants l'arrivée fonds
massives les régulières de migrants
depuis le début de l'année le long de la
mer on arrivait ont baissé de 77 %
c'est ça la réalité la crise des
migrants de 2015 est derrière nous un
traitement cryogène médiatique nous a
demandé de mettre la démonstration à m à
l'insu de votre plein gré on va dire mon
journal même chose fait d une là dessus
c'est pas vrai je veux dire qu on est
500 millions d'européens et on a eu ou
plus lors du sommet franco-allemand
d'hier donc on n'a rien inventé non plus
non mais parce que c'est parce que mon
poids parce qu elle est l homme gai là
merkel est prise en otage par sa droite
radicale de la c'est ce qu'elle m'aime
bien en otage par l'extrême droite de
l'afd et donc c'est des affaires de
politique intérieure c'est simplement
c'est un ressenti vis à vis des opinions
publiques et de ross a ressenti des
partis politiques et notamment et des
partis d'extrême droite qui ont font à
leur fonds de commerce
si tous donc il faut il n'y a pas de
crise des migrants je dis aux
téléspectateurs il n'y a pas de crise
des migrants
faut arrêter avec ça marie christine
vergiat je suis d'accord y'a pas de
crise des migrants mais on n'arrête pas
tout un chacun de parler de la crise des
migrants voilà il ya une crise de
l'accueil mais il ya une crise
européenne par rapport à ça c'est parce
qu'on a laissé un certain nombre de pays
l'italie la grèce l'allemagne seul face
à par rapport à cet accueil des réfugiés
des sens qui sont d'abord et avant tout
des réfugiés en grande majorité par
notamment des syriens et heureusement
que madame merkel
parce que madame merkel a accueilli 60 %
des syriens qui sont arrivés sur le sol
le sol de l'union européenne donc de
coucou moi je suis pourtant pas très
proche politiquement de madame merkel
bon mais quand même je trouve que quand
on quand j'entends gérard collomb se
dire qu'on a même le même là on ne prend
les même hargne et voilà quand j'entends
monsieur
collomb nous expliquer qu'il ya des
régions en france qui sont submergés je
suis dit non mais de quoi on parle en
baie et moi je pense que on court après
l'extrême droite
donc là je suis en désaccord avec jean
quatremer c'est parce que nous n'avons
pas de politique de solidarité
européenne
parce que dublin n'a pas été changé par
rapport à la politique du premier rang
du premier pays entrants parce que
monsieur macro continue de courir après
ce leur a renvoyé les gens vers le pays
est le pays première en trois que nous
continuerons à avoir des problèmes
l'italie va continuer à faire son cinéma
monsieur salsa non feinte je ne suis pas
entièrement d'accord sur le constat je
suis en partie vraiment en phase avec ce
que nos amis disent on peut pas dire
qu'il n'ya pas de crise il ya 15000
morts en méditerranée
drm
il ya une prise de conscience à avoir de
la part des politiques
et ça n'est pas en surfant derrière les
idées populistes qui sont simplistes qui
utilise la peur la haine xénophobie
languedoc et pas comme moteur nous
devient ont révisé dublin et ce sont les
formes et les accords de dublin sont
hypocrites le sens demandé l'alignement
au pays ce sont les candidats qui
avaient les pieds oui ça change de la
devise et personne ne veut changer en
europe
persona par le parlement européen ne
veut changer le règlement de dublin qui
je rappelle remonte à il ya près de 30
ans était d'abord une convention et
c'est l'idée c'est simplement que
lorsqu'un demandeur d'asile
tu peux je parle pas d'un migrant
économie arrive dans un pays il doit
demander l'asile dans le premier pays
d'accueil ce qui est une façon en fait
de pousser l'italie la grèce et
l'espagne à surveiller les frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne sauf
qu'on les trente ans après les choses
ont totalement changé
il est clair qu'il faut changer cette
règle parce que ça veut dire plus ne
sais pas qui c'est mais je ne m'abuse
les gens en italie ne sont souvent pas
enregistré donc pour lui dès qu'on les
renvoie ainsi l'essentiel maintenant
c'est fait furet frontex a été renforcée
moi je vis des fonds importants pour mon
groupe sur frontex
on a amélioré gta iv times la semaine
dernière qu'on dépense 1 milliards en
euros pour sécuriser les frontières ou
qu'on peut dire qu'on fait rien
non on peut pas dire ces maliens ont
fait mal on a progressé on a avancé mais
on peut pas dire qu'il ya pas de crise
il ya une crise la réponse est
européenne c'est bien que ça avance mais
je trouve que les nathalie guida sort du
sommet vers là dessus at on dit y'a pas
de crise humanitaire montré humanitaire
et oui mais l'accueil abbas en recul de
l'accueil comment crise de l'accueil
comment la france accueille tels ces
migrants nos reporters ont suivi
l'itinéraire d'un réfugiés somaliens en
errance à paris c'est un reportage
d'alice rougerie et françois boulay ans
regarde porte de la chapelle à paris à
côté du périphérique
des dizaines de migrants installés au
bord de la route au milieu des détritus
tous les jours ici ils peuvent manger et
boire
tu es là tu m'as les bénévoles de
l'association utopia organise la
distribution des repas
un premier petit déjeuner en france pour
saïd arrivé la veille d'italie mais ce
que vient surtout chercher ici ce
somalien de 21 ans
c'est une carte sim pour son téléphone
car avant toute chose il doit
s'enregistrer auprès des services de
l'immigration
aidé par ce bénévole à la j'ai pris son
nom son prénom sa date de naissance et
sa masse humilité et combien de jours
qu'il est là donc ce monsieur vous savez
un jour donc il est arrivé il ya la
demande de rendez-vous est géré par
téléphone uniquement
et c'est pareil pour tout le monde ici
alors les chargeurs tournent jour et
nuit
en attendant la réponse de l'office de
l'immigration
saïd nous montre où il a passé sa
première nuit en france à quelques
mètres de là il faut traverser plusieurs
fois l'entrée du périphérique avant
d'arriver sous ce pot
je cherchais un endroit pour dormir et
là bas ils m'ont dit de venir ici il y
avait du monde
on était une vingtaine cette nuit un
matelas et des cartons à même le sol
et pour se chauffer un duvet que saïd
cache pendant la journée
c'est le vôtre celui là oui c'est le
mien vous l'avez trouvé où les gens là
bas me l'ont donné hier
pendant ce temps slimane t d'harry le
bénévole est toujours en ligne avec
l'office de l'immigration
la date de naissance et le 28 02 1997 le
cas de saïd est complexe car il est du
bli nez il a été contrôlé en italie mais
veut déposer son dossier en france
or selon les accords de dublin le
migrant doit faire sa demande d'asile
dans le premier pays européen où il a
été contrôlé la fessée emprunta en
italie lasses et en france donc c'est
pour ça que c'est un peu compliqué donc
il peut à tout moment atrix qc en est à
dire on est à lire vos hauts perchés rue
chez lui c'est la somalie un pays en
guerre
saïd nous explique avoir dû fuir les
combats son périple pour arriver ici a
commencé il y a un an et cinq mois
en somalie c'est la guerre la guerre et
le terrorisme et il tue des gens c'est
invivable
au moins ici même si je dors dehors je
dors en paix je n'ai pas peur pendant la
nuit je n'ai pas peur des gens en
somalie je ne peux pas dormir comme ça
si je faisais ça en somalie en jeu la
réponse de l'office de l'immigration
vient de tomber
saïd est convoqué il va pouvoir demander
l'asile politique
son souhait rester en france trouver un
travail et sutout quitter la porte de la
chapelle pour une vraie maison
[Musique]
un peu
voilà portage d'alice rougerie et
françois goulard quand vous voyez ce
reportage vous dites quoi
on fait mieux dans l'accueil j'aiguise
notamment la première chose c'est
contrairement il adlène la journaliste
dit deux choses contradictoires elle dit
le du bim et doit être renvoyée et
finalement ce monsieur voit sa demande
acceptée dans le règlement de dublin
s'est effectivement ça le premier pays
entrants est obligé d'accepter y compris
le renvoi alors que le pays vers lequel
il ya un mouvement secondaire pour
utiliser le vocabulaire européen n'est
pas obligé de renvoyer et compte tenu de
la situation de la france je pense qu'un
certain nombre de gens devraient voir
leur demande d'asile acceptée en france
examinée conformément à la convention de
genève parce que le règlement dublin
tels qu'ils existent c'est elle qu'on
veut le durcir tels que les états
membres veulent le dire tirs c'est
contraire à la convention de justice etc
seront déjà ce personne a le droit de
voir sa demande examinée individuel ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'on a
l'air de dire que les gens qui viennent
chercher l'asile en europe devrait
déposer leur demande dans leur pays
d'origine c'est quasiment ça on consomme
à vie voire l'allier à l'ambassade de
france et l'ambassade de france au mali
c'est à dire que les gens pour demander
l'asile ils doivent justement essayer
d'arriver sur le territoire et la
convention de genève ne prévoit
absolument pas inapte aux absolument pas
une entrée régulière sur le territoire
vous imaginez les juifs fuyant
l'allemagne nazie et qui demande en
allemagne leur leur statut de réfugié en
france ou qui attendent sagement la
frontière non à l'époque il fallait
essayer de passer les frontières dans
n'importe quelle circonstance c'est ce
que font ces gens je parle des
demandeurs d'asile autres choses sont
les oignons par le magazine la semaine à
cette demande en verve il est en
revanche les vip pour la revanche pour
les migrants mon à cet institut et c'est
une problématique complètement
différente pour les immigrés économiques
il ne keane qui ne recoupent que très
partiellement la problématique demandeur
d'asile et que l'on mélange allègrement
la lisez les en revanche l'immigration
économique c'est aussi un problème il
faut quand même que les gens sachent que
le vieillissement de l'europe fait que à
terme on aura besoin est de plus en plus
besoin de d'immigrés pour payer nos
retraites c'est aussi simple que ça pour
travailler pour occuper les places dans
les usines
on remarque d'ailleurs que lorsque pour
l'immigration économique que lorsqu'une
crise économique violente en europe
curieusement les arrivées dix minutes
brutalement
quand l'économie va bien les arrivées
recommence les gens viennent pour
travailler et l'erreur gravissime qu'on
a fait en europe c'est qu'on a on a
institué ce mythe de l'europe frontières
de l'europe forteresse de l'immigration
zéro n'existe pas mais pourquoi alors on
a rendu la france hostile aux mille
soixante ans on a 30 ans de front
national en face d'une part que le
discours alors si on est très proches
donc c'est pas la peine de rajouter
cette mêlée leur corps est en réalité
pas suivant cette confusion entre
migrants économies y constitue peut-être
une des formes de réponse pour notre
europe à moyen long terme
évidemment puisqu'on et l'europe aux
cheveux gris et que les les ça a
toujours existé ce brassage et on en a
besoin il faut pas confondre ça avec les
critères qui doivent être européen pour
les gens qui fuient la violence et les
guerres et qu'ils ne constituent qu'une
minorité c'est vrai que merkel est la
seule à avoir répondu à cela
mais aujourd'hui pour les allemands et
pour les autres européens
ils ont le sentiment qu'elles payent
politiquement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle elle recule et donc qu'il est
nécessaire d'avoir une réponse
européenne c'est inadmissible que les
pays du nord donne des leçons pays du
sud qui accueille et c'est inadmissible
de ne pas avoir une réponse européenne
c'est celle du sud c'est ça la c'est ça
la solution mais c'est pas juste faire
le constat que les extrêmes monte monte
monte aujourd'hui et c'est ça qui
maximise on aime encore et qu'on se
dirige droit vers effectivement des
centres de rétention aux frontières on
va sous traiter les jeunes en délire à
la turquie de malaise est déjà à l'arrêt
anisé oui bien sûr seulement les gens
d'ici et c'est gravissime
parce que encore une fois dire que c'est
on abandonne l'ensemble de nos valeurs
donc on ne peut pas adopter une réponse
qui sont uniquement répressive il faut
au contraire avoir une politique
proactive pourquoi est-ce que je parlais
de la fermeture des frontières
tout simplement parce que ça a été un
mythe et ça trop au lieu de laisser les
gens venir en europe contiennent du
travail et repartir quand il y en a pas
laissé vivre au monde qu'est ce qu'on
fait une fois qu'on a passé la frontière
on ne repart plus jamais c'est aussi
simple que ça parce que on est
tranquille on est sur place et c'est
nous qui avons créé des problèmes qui me
ok iberia voulait laisser circuler on a
des réponses à apporter les politiques
fassent qu'à déplacer dans de vieilles
batteries d'accord à ce ressenti de peur
de les réparer a tellement européenne
elles doivent faire bouger à chaque
année il ya deux cent cinquante mille
personnes qui arrivent régulièrement sur
le sol français il y en a deux millions
cinq cent mille qui arrive sur le sol
européen
parmi eux un quart de migrants
économiques et on n'en parle pas de ces
gens là il ya une différence entre les
pays du nord et les pays du sud c'est
les pays du sud dont on ne veut pas et
leur cd d'anciennes colonies dont on ne
peut leur souhaiter que l'immigration tu
viens de l'est celle là elle est
acceptée oui la première nature là la
première nationalité regarder les
chiffres je prends les paris puis la
première nationalité qui arrive sur le
sol de l'union européenne avec des
titres de séjour régulier qui sont des
titres de travail ce sont les ukrainiens
ce sont les ukrainiens qui arrive en
pologne et la pologne commence à le dire
parce qu'on commence à lui dire ça elle
refuse les gens du sud elle refuse des
réfugiés mais c'est le pays qui
acceptent le plus de migrants
économiques
donc on sorte de discours entre les bons
réfugiés et les mauvais migrants mais
bon on vous montrait un dernier
reportage très court à la société civile
dans tout cela tous ne sont pas fermées
je voulais vous montrer cette initiative
à vous y étiez marie christine vergiat
des vues de vintimille à calais en
passant par paris une marche solidaire
pour les migrants on regarde et on
réagit juste après tu fais la première
est abattu
ils sont un peu plus d'un millier à
battre le pavé parisien
ils ont rejoint une dizaine de marcheurs
partis fin avril de la frontière
franco-italienne halte ici à paris pour
dire non au blocage des frontières non
au délit de solidarité
ap parmi les soutiens
l'eurodéputé écologiste karima delli la
france est la sixième puissance mondiale
qu'on vienne pas me dire qu'on n'est pas
capable d'accueillir des enfants des
femmes enceintes et même des hommes
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la france doit
regarder son histoire le meilleur modèle
c'est lorsqu'elle a ouvert ses
frontières at plus de 200 mille votes
people ça c'est la grandeur de la france
rami hamdi à 19 ans il est égyptien il
est arrivé il ya un mois en france
il est passé par le suit dans la libye
puis l'italie avant d'atterrir dans un
squat à aubervilliers aujourd'hui il
dort dehors je mets de squat en squat
des fois je dors deux jours dehors on se
débrouille comme on peut ici
moi j'aime la france si je réussis avoir
des papiers je reste sinon je ferais
comme en libye en italie continuent à
l'aider pour un accueil véritable des
migrants c'est aussi le but de cette
marche de 1400 km ils rallieront calais
début juillet puis londres en transport
[Musique]
vergers sont minoritaires ces marcheurs
c'est la société civile minoritaires
face aux scellés ligne dure là qui
l'emportent en ce moment dans l'opinion
dans le fan je sais pas dans l'opinion
et à plus en plus par ailleurs je pense
que le rôle des politiques n'est pas de
cours et après l'opinion publique en
1981 françois mitterrand a abrogé la
peine de mort il était à contre-courant
de l'opinion publique
je crois que les rôles des politiques et
notamment quand soucier dits
progressistes humanisme c'est de parler
des chiffres tels qu'ils sont réellement
un mois je m'emploie à ça en permanence
parce qu'on est en train de nous
caricaturer les choses et plus ça va
plus on court après les démagogues et
après l'extrême droite laisse quand même
ce ressenti 1 / / / eux ces migrants
associée à tort à une invasion à la
religion musulmane dans mes bras du
terrorisme potentiel rejet à augmenter
prédit le roger il existe et il faut pas
se leurrer entre les deux guerres par
exemple à l'égard de l'immigration
italienne était considéré comme étant
trop catholique à catholicisme trop fan
des grilles c'est donc pas réintégrer
les crêpes à la française aujourd'hui
c'est clair qu'en france qui accueille
c'est la principale population musulmane
à des migrations 8 8% d'après les
chiffres donnés par un institut
américain qui s'appelle priori search on
a l'impression quand on interroge les
gens l'ont dit bien combien de musulmans
en france
les gens répondent 30% servir huit
personnes
c'est ça la réalité et au niveau
européen ces 4 9% même si ça a beaucoup
augmenté au cours des deux dernières
années à cause de l'immigration va
causer des récits bien voilà c'est la
seule raison
une envoyée le ressenti parce qu'il ya
effectivement des concentrations
certaines zones c'est qu'on est en
veille la réalité c'est faute sur le 500
millions d'européens on est très très
loin mais de voir nos cultures je
voulais dispard voulait conclure sur les
solutions à l'idée de pays tiers sur un
voulue par merkel créé autour de
l'europe une sorte de ceinture sur
lesquelles on pourrait renvoyer les gens
qui entrent en europe c'est une solution
c'est à travailler en tous les cas et
surtout travailler plus intelligemment à
l'aide aux pays tiers en matière de
développement pour que les gens n'aient
pas envie nécessaire de repartir mais je
voudrais ajouter parmi eux on est tous
le fruit de brassage on est tous
on a tous des racines différentes mais
en ce qui concerne
la politique l'engagement politique
c'est pas de regarder les trains passer
c'est de quand même entendre ce que les
gens comprennent expliqué entre et s'il
le faut dans les distinctions là
effectivement dans l'opinion publique
tout le monde mélange tout et ne
distingue pas entre quelqu'un qui fuit
la guerre qui fuit son pays
quelqu'un qui veut qu'ils qui souhaitent
venir travailler ou quelqu'un qui vient
étudier en europe
tout ça est mélangé et et mixé avec les
extrêmes et aboutit à ce rejet donc le
politique il doit entendre et il doit
essayer d'avoir un temps d'avancé et
décider si on arrive à la fin de cette
émission à ses pairs européens mais
européen fin juin va être important sur
sur ce sujet il faudra une réponse
claire je rappelle qu'il ya des
élections européennes le 26 mai prochain
voilà c'est la fin d'europe hebdo ra
mais c'est un parlement européen qui
prend aussi position qu'il n'ya pas que
le conseil
bien évidemment berry vide avant des
élections européennes donc l'année
prochaine voilà c'est la fin d'europe
hebdo merci à vous trois d'être venus
débattre avec nous merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis rester avec nous sur les
chaînes parlementaires et la rtbf bail
[Musique]
c